we talked on the podcast you talked
about therapy
i don't want to pry too much but are you
still getting therapy
are you still talking to a therapist
during this crazy time i would think you
should be
i always i always talk to therapists i i
have a team i always have multiple
multiple therapists working you act like
it's a law firm like you have
nine therapists i have two therapists
they know about each other i've had a
lot of therapists
i went to a therapist for a while uh
many years ago it was he was recommended
by uh
by gary chandling by gary
and he uh and i went to see him for a
while and then i was in the
lobby of his place waiting and they were
all the books that he wrote
and the book that he wrote was uh this
book
total orgasm
and i was like what is going on
with this book and then there's all
these pictures in it they're
very they're kind of dirty pictures i'm
not sure what
jesus and i said to gary i said gary you
didn't tell me the
therapist you sent me to was the total
orgasm guy
and gary's like i never talked about
orgasms with him
i don't know what that is so did you
ever bring it up to the therapist i mean
he must know
these incredible secrets i literally got
scared to ask him for orgasm advice
i should have asked him and then i said
to gary how's it going with that
therapist
like a year later and he's like oh i
left him
i mean you're not allowed to recommend a
therapist decide you don't like him
and then not tell me that i should leave
too
you have to we have to do it together
that was a betrayal
that was a deep betrayal when we see
gary in the next
plane the next we will i swear to god
we're gonna see gary again and we should
just confront him with all the things
that he did that annoyed us
everything that he did wrong now's the
time we should start really ganging up
on gary we're gonna have an eternity
uh with him at some point so we might as
well just get it off our chest
there'll be time to hash it out